- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV
program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(classical music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(mellow piano music)
- I'd like to begin by
acknowledging and appreciating the talk
that I just heard, which
really emphasized this,
that animals and humans
can get the same diseases
and yet physicians and veterinarians
rarely consult with one another,
and that human and non-human
animal commonalities
can be used to diagnose, threat,
and heal patients of all species.
And I also would like to acknowledge
that this comes as Barbara pointed out
from a long lineage
that goes back to Oslo,
and one of those steps along the way
was one of our own here, Kurt Benirschke,
unfortunately couldn't be
here because of an illness,
the founding director of CRESZS
and professor of pathology here
who really emphasized one medicine.
I'd like to flip the coin around,
and science has always
two sides to every coin,
and say, are there
human-specific diseases?
What we've been hearing
about is the evolutionary
biology and diseases of a
large variety of animals,
mostly warm-blooded social
animals, vertebrates,
and you can see an entire lineage here.
Let's zoom in on the
group that we belong to,
primates, and zoom in further,
and among these primates
we have new-world monkeys,
old-world monkeys, gibbons,
various so-called great apes,
and then us, humans.
If we zoom in further here,
we can see that we shared common ancestors
with orangutans, gorillas,
chimpanzees, bonobos
just a very short time
ago in evolutionary time.
And here's another way to look at it.
In millions of years before present,
there's certainly some
discussion about the time frame,
but the very important
point to make here is that
while we classified all
these species as great apes,
the main difference between
chimpanzees and bonobos
is less than 1% of their
amino acid sequence level.
In fact, we are closer to
bonobos and chimpanzees
than they are to gorillas.
In fact, we are closer to chimpanzees
than mice and rats are to each other.
So really, the classification
should be like this,
we are hominids, and
then among the hominids,
the lineage is leading
to us, the hominins.
So if you have a species that's 99%
identical to us at the protein level,
how could you possibly have anything
that's different between them?
And in fact, when I first
got into this field,
I found out at the veterinarians that
the primates center I went to were using
Harrison's textbook of internal medicine,
same textbook I'd used.
So that made sense.
But if you wanna say there's such a thing
as a human-specific disease,
it's got to be very common in humans,
rarely reported in
closely-related species,
now this is very important,
I'm zooming in on this
clip, not about things
that happened at distant
portions of evolution,
even in captivity and could not
be experimentally reproduced
in such species, and I should warn you,
I'm gonna talk about a few
really horrible experiments
that were done a long time ago
that will never be done again.
So there's a caveat:
who do you compare with?
In my opinion, reliable
information is limited
to data on a few thousand
great apes in captivity
which were cared for at
NIH-funded facilities,
with full veterinary care,
probably better medical care
than most Americans get,
and full necropsies.
Sp this is a reasonable data
said to compare with humans.
I think comparing with wild chimpanzees
and self-domesticated
humans isn't that useful
in this question that
we are trying to ask.
So when I went to Yerkes Primate Center
and other centers and asked, and said,
"What's the commonest cause of death
"in captive adult chimpanzees?"
And they said, "Heart disease,
"heart attacks, heart failures."
So I said, "Oh, it's the same thing."
But then my wife, Nissi
Varki, who's a pathologist,
went to see what is going on.
She came back and said,
"You fool, it's mostly
a different disease!"
And so we got together with
various experts across,
including Kurt, and wrote
this article that says
Heart Disease is Common
in Humans and Chimpanzees,
But is mostly Caused by
Different Pathological Processes.
So in comparing these two species,
amazingly, it turns out
that while we humans,
essentially all of our heart attacks
are due to what you heard about,
atherosclerotic coronary
blockade in the arteries,
chimpanzees do get atherosclerosis,
but it rarely ever leads
to coronary thrombosis.
Instead, they get this
very peculiar kind of
scarring in the myocardium,
in the heart muscle, fibrosis,
so-called interstitial myocardial
fibrosis in great apes.
This gives rise to abnormal
rhythms, heart failure,
and heart attacks, so it looks like humans
but in autopsies, it's
a different disease.
In fact, since we wrote this article now
put this out, it's
become so well-recognized
that interstitial myocardial
fibrosis is such a
major common in captive
great apes in all the zoos
that all the zoos led by Zoo
Atlanta have gotten together
and found a network to figure
out what is this disease,
and why is it killing all our great apes.
And so there are two
mysteries to be solved.
One is, why do we humans not often get
this fibrotic heart
disease that's so common
in our closest evolutionary cousins?
Conversely, why do
great apes not often get
the kind of heart disease we get
that's so common in humans?
Since we're genetically so similar,
there must be a very
limited number of reasons.
We'd immediately say, "Ah,
it's just cholesterol."
In fact, cholesterol is the leading thing
that pushes atherosclerotic heart disease,
but look at this figure here.
Above is the black line,
chimpanzee levels of cholesterol.
Even at birth and soon after
birth in the first decade,
they're so high that they
should be on statins.
And they have similar HDL levels.
They have APOE4 ancestral
allele, higher Lp(a) levels,
sedentary lifestyles,
hypertension, and so on.
Now, to be fair, there are
some amino acid differences
in those two very important proteins
and that may be part of the story.
So based on this kind of
work, Nissi Varki and I
went to several of these primate centers
and tried to learn more about
this biomedical differences.
In this case, we're
focusing on differences.
I wanna be clear, there
are many similarities,
which I'm not gonna talk about.
And so we, of course, worked
on sialic acid biology.
That's another story for another day,
but this article also talks
about those differences.
So here's a list of candidates
for human-specific diseases
that I call definite,
meaning the data so far
suggest that long list.
Obviously, I'm not going to
go through the whole list.
I'll give you a few examples.
The big one, of course,
that I mentioned is this
remarkable difference in the
rates of coronary thrombosis
was this interstitial myocardial fibrosis.
In fact, spontaneous coronary thrombosis
due to atherosclerosis
seems to be very rare
in other animals, in the
absence of experimental
genetic or dietary manipulations.
And the human-specific mechanics,
undoubtedly as mentioned,
have to do partly with
behavioral and dietary changes,
although I'm looking forward
to the talk from Mike Gurvin
on this hunter-gatherer heart disease,
these amino acid changes
in these two proteins,
and something I'm not gonna go into,
genetic change in sialic
acid that seems to have
made our immune cells much
more prone to inflammation
and also contributes to the effects
of red meat and heart attacks,
but that's, of course, a specialized case.
Here's another disease, malignant malaria,
the big killer malaria.
Horrible, horrible
studies done in the 1920s
and 1940s in the Belgian Congo,
two-way cross-transfusions
between chimpanzees
and humans infected or
non-infected with malaria.
No evidence of across infection.
It turned out the parasites look the same
but are different.
Fast forward almost a century and work by
CARTA member Francisco
Ayala and others showed
that all the falciparum in
the world, this killer malaria
belongs to a very small
plate in the midst of
many, many, many other ape malarias.
In fact, Barbara Han later showed
that Plasmodium falciparum probably arose
by a single transfer from
one gorilla to a human,
sometime we don't know exactly when,
a few tens of thousands of years ago.
So Pascal Gagneuxa
summarized it like this.
Ape malarias are very common,
and because of the sialic acid change,
I'm not going to go into,
we escaped the target
and we had a free ride
for a million years or so,
but the parasites always win in the end.
And finally the parasite
in that one transfer
switched to bind the
human kind of sialic acid
and then, of course,
we spread to mosquitoes
in our environment, and
the rest is history.
Here's another one,
typhoid fever, big killer
throughout human history
until very recently.
And it turns out there's been
a host adaptation to humans.
Again, most horrible
studies done in the 1960s,
large doses of Salmonella type
fever given to chimpanzees.
Survival was much better, and
they were much less sensitive.
It turns out we can find
an explanation for this.
There's a human kind of sialic acid
shown on this side of the screen,
and the other side of the screen,
Gc is the chimpanzee type of sialic acid.
And the typhoid toxin only binds
to the human kind of sialic acid.
And so using most models,
we can sort of show
that this is what's going on,
that we have the
sensitivity and resistance.
Cholera, Robert Koch, the
famous microbiologist said,
"Although these experiments
are constantly repeated
"with material from fresh cholera cases,
"our mice remained healthy.
"We then made experiments
on monkeys, cats,
"poultry, dogs, and other animals,
"and we were never able
to arrive at anything
"similar to a cholera process."
So far, there's nothing
except a baby rabbit model.
Of course, there's explanation for this.
Now I've been talking mostly
about infectious disease
from Jared Diamond and others,
and if you look in the
bottom of the screen,
you can see that certain
diseases like rabies
can spread throughout many animals.
And then eventually a disease
makes its way into humans
and by what's called the red queen effect,
becomes highly specialized on one species.
And so some of this is not so surprising,
but the fact is that
there are such diseases.
There's one set of definite diseases
that are kinda interesting.
These are gonorrhea,
various other organisms
that infect newborns.
But it appears that these
bacteria have done is
invent the human kind of
sialic acid and coat themselves
in what my colleague, Victor
Nizet, calls molecular mimicry,
basically wolves in sheep's clothing.
And they're very successful pathogens.
Okay, so that's some examples.
I haven't gone through all of
them human-specific diseases
that seem to be human-specific.
What about probable ones?
Alzheimer's Disease.
Another CARTA member, Doc
Finch has written this.
Commentary: is Alzheimer's
disease uniquely human?
"That Alzheimer's disease may
be a human-specific disease
"was hypothesized in 1989.
"Apes accumulate considerable
amyloid plaques after 40,
"an age at which these
are uncommon in humans.
"Despite this early
plaque buildup, ape brains
"have not shown dystrophic
neurites near plaques.
"Aging great ape brains
also have few tangles.
"We cautiously support this hypothesis."
And this is under further investigation.
Carcinomas of epithelial origin.
To date, of these few thousand
apes cared for in captivity,
not a single case of
carcinoma of the esophagus,
lung, stomach, pancreas, colon,
uterus, ovary or prostate.
And so Nissi and I looked
into this and concluded that
while relative carcinoma
risk is a likely difference
between humans and
chimpanzees and other apes,
a more systematic survey is needed.
Of course, age is a factor,
not just environment.
And so you'd say, well,
a lot of these diseases
we're mentioning have to do with age.
But in fact, chimpanzees
in captivity can live
up to the age of 45, 50,
occasionally even up to 60.
And so they are in the age range,
if you're looking at the
rates of human cancer here
in human males and females,
but you might expect
to at least see a few carcinomas,
a few heart attacks of the human kind
and a few early cases of
Alzheimer's-like disease,
but none have been seen.
Possible examples.
Another long list.
And here we have what is
called absence of evidence,
it's not evidence of absence.
We really don't know.
But it's kinda interesting
that bronchial asthma,
I've been looking for a
case of bronchial asthma
in a great ape, or for
that matter, in a monkey,
and there's no papers about this,
except the papers like this.
Here's a paper about
the asthma-like syndrome
in a single monkey that says
"The present case is remarkable
"in that there's a paucity of
reports of naturally occurring
"allergy airway disease
in non-human primates."
This could have to do with
the hygiene hypothesis.
Other issues remains to be seen.
Anyway, to conclude,
disease profiles of humans
and chimpanzees are rather different,
considering how
genetically similar we are.
Chimpanzees, contrary to the original idea
of NIH and health
sciences, are poor models
of many human disease,
and should not be used
to model human diseases
very often, if at all.
Humans, conversely, are
likely to be poor models
of many chimpanzee diseases.
So there are huge ethical issues here.
Chimpanzees are sentient beings.
I wouldn't do anything to a chimpanzee
I wouldn't do it to a human,
and with even greater
care than with humans.
And back in 2005, Jim
More, Pascal Gagneuxa and I
wrote this ethics paper.
We suggested that we conduct
research on great apes
following principles generally similar
to those accepted for human research,
and even suggested that the researchers
should volunteer to be
subjects in the same studies.
(audience laughing)
Since I wrote this, I keep getting these
letters saying, "Please sign this document
"banning all future
research on chimpanzees."
And my answer is, "That's a terrible idea.
"Would you ban all future
research on humans?"
But unfortunately, that's what's happened
for other reasons, really good reasons of
getting chimpanzees out of
not-very-good facilities
and avoiding invasive research.
Then I just threw up its hand on this,
stopped all chimpanzee
research, practically speaking.
And the question is, will the
ban on chimpanzee research
actually do more harm
than good to both species?
And add to that a final corollary,
chimpanzees would benefit
from more ethical studies
of their own diseases,
and I'm hoping that we can still keep
this area of research open because
I think it's important for
both humans and chimpanzees
and the diseases that we both get.
Thank you.
(mellow piano music)
- One out of every four deaths
basically in the US and the UK
are from heart disease.
So it's basically the number one killer,
not just in the industrialized world,
and a major source of cost
burning our health care system,
but also around the world,
including in developing world,
that heart disease and its
more insidious form of it,
atherosclerosis, is the source of say,
every three out of 10 deaths
around the world today.
So it's so familiar to us
that the obvious question is
well, is atherosclerosis
really a universal aspect
of just human aging?
It's sort of an inevitable aspect.
By the time you're 20,
you probably already have
some of the fatty streaks
that will later go on
to become more complicated lesions
and create problems for us.
Or is that not the case?
And so, maybe atherosclerosis,
the process is universal
but maybe it does or
does not always present
clinical manifestations that
will affect our morbidity,
and ultimately, mortality.
So a standard kind of
story is that if we could
zoom back into the past and
look at hunter-gatherers,
that hunter-gatherers
wouldn't have these types
of heart disease, or
other types of problems,
and that it's modern
features of our lifestyle
that is making us ill,
that there's a mismatch
between our genetic adaptations
and modern features of lifestyle.
So changes in our nutrition, our diet,
our physical activity, our
bad habits as Barbara said,
like cigarette smoking
and alcohol consumption,
that these are maybe
what create the problem,
and that hunter-gatherers
would have little
or no coronary heart disease.
And the evidence for this is often
focused on some risk factors,
so cholesterol, Type II
diabetes, low prevalence,
that their risk factors seem
to suggest a healthy heart.
But there are some problems here is that
we don't really know
that in these types of populations
that heart disease is fairly absent.
First of all, the
numbers are fairly small.
And often, there'd be a
medical team, like in the 1950s
or 60s that would sweep through a village,
but fairly quickly.
And so, it could be that
people who have heart disease
died fairly quickly from it,
and so unless you've spent
a long time in an area,
you might not actually see the real cases
if the case fatality rate is quite high.
And it could be that,
you know, those people
got weeded out of the population early.
And so if you looked at
people over the age of 60,
no one has heart disease maybe because
they died earlier on in life.
But also, the assessment
is fairly indirect
as I mentioned, you know, it's easy
to kind of take someone's blood pressure,
to measure how much cholesterol they have,
to measure their BMI, but it's much harder
to get a direct assessment.
And of course, if certain risk factors
worked differently in
different human populations,
then it might not be a
one-to-one relationship
that the risk factors tell you about
the actual underlying heart disease.
And one good example from the 70s,
was kind of became a
established fact almost
that the Inuit up near the arctic north,
and in Alaska and Greenland in particular,
that they don't have atherosclerosis,
and they don't have heart disease,
and particularly their marine-rich diet
and particularly omega-3s
was one good reason
why despite a very meat-based diet,
that they would not have heart disease.
But it actually turns out there were some
unreliable mortality statistics
some of those earlier
inferences were based on
and further kind of x-ray
and ultrasound studies
actually show the opposite,
that there is quite a decent
amount of atherosclerosis
and that heart disease didn't
really look that different
from near surrounding populations,
and that stroke might even be higher.
And also, more recent meta-analyses show
no effect of omega-3 fish
oils on heart-related deaths,
heart attacks and strokes.
So the standard story is
actually a little bit different
when you look into it in more detail.
And also, the Horus group, which we'll see
a little bit more further in the talk,
looked at a unique sample of 137 mummies
across four world regions, so
ancient Egypt, ancient Peru,
the southwest of the US,
and the Aleutian Islands,
and across 4,000 years of history,
and he looked at different arterial beds
for evidence of calcification.
So a more direct measure using CT scans,
whole body CT scans of these mummies.
So for example, here you've got,
these are both two Unangan
women from the Aleutian Islands,
up here, is woman about
50, here a woman about 30,
and you can see some
evidence of calcification
in the aortic arch on top
and in the carotid artery
down here on the bottom.
And what they found was
evidence of calcification
across all arterial beds,
across all four populations.
And so they argued that,
their conclusion was that
we found that heart disease
is a serial killer that's
been stalking mankind
for thousands of years.
The presence of atherosclerosis
in pre-modern human beings
suggests that the disease
is an inherent component
of human aging, and not characteristic
of any specific diet or lifestyle.
So now the paleo diet
people hated this, right,
because they were basically
saying, "Look, it's all over,
"it doesn't matter what you eat.
"We find evidence of this everywhere."
But of course, all the
mummies have been long dead
so it's hard to know what
they actually died of
and whether that atherosclerosis
might have been relevant
to their daily lives.
Now also, if we're riding
off of Adjit's talk,
we now know that chimpanzees,
while the number one
cause of death in captives
is heart attacks, it's not exactly coming
from the same ideology
as human heart attacks
That chimpanzees do not seem to have
the same kind of atherosclerosis,
coronary artery disease is rare,
but the heart failure
instead is through this
diffused interstitial myocardial fibrosis
often triggered by arrythmias.
You can see the diffused kind of
fibrosis in the heart
tissue in chimpanzees,
the kind of sub-endothelial plaques
in the human interior lumen,
that this is very different.
And in captive chimpanzees,
despite the fact
that they have higher cholesterol levels,
they're homozygous for
alleles in the ApoE4
that are higher risk of
atherosclerosis in humans
and less physical activity,
so quite remarkable difference.
Now the standard kind
of evolutionary story
brought to us by some
evolutionary biologists
in the critical foundational contributions
Medawar as well as Holdane and Hamilton,
that basically that the force of selection
declines with age as
fertility is dropping,
so the relative contributions
for future generations
are declining, and so
you can have mutations
that exert effects late
in life that might be
somewhat blind to the
effects of natural selection,
especially if they have
beneficial effects early in life.
So what that means is that
you've got deleterious effects
that manifest, say, later in life,
fall under the selection shadow.
And it actually turns out
when you actually look at the cases,
this is from US data, the actual incidence
of heart attacks and fail
coronary heart disease,
that those cases do fall
into this selection shadow.
So one kind of knee-jerk
response is, well, maybe
again, these things have
always been with us,
but in hunter-gatherers, if you're not
gonna live to this kind of age range,
then you're not gonna see
these types of ailments.
And so that might be the end of story,
and that our longer
lives in modern society
is why we see so much more of it today.
But that doesn't really
seem to be the case.
If we take some of the
best demographic data
out there on hunter-gatherers
as kind of a key,
obviously, living
hunter-gatherers are not the same
as our ancestors, but it's
the closest thing we have
to try to understand
what life and mortality
might be like without
all the modern amenities.
And so, in hunter-gatherers
where the average
life expectancy at birth
is in the either high 20s
or low 30s, compared to what we're used to
in the US and other first-world countries
is a dramatic difference.
But if you notice, this is the ratio
of the mortality in hunter-gatherers,
say, the American mortality
and it's quite high,
the difference, but most
of those differences
are early in life.
And that by the time
you get to, say age 15,
the mortality difference
has dropped from, say 200,
early in life to 14 times
higher in hunter-gatherers,
to about age 40, seven times
and by age 60, that mortality difference
is only three times higher.
So if you live past this
early period of high mortality
and you survived to age 15, the mortal age
of adult death is actually
it ranges from 68 to 78
in this hunter-gatherer populations.
So it's not probably the case
that the absence of older people
is why we don't see
these types of problems
presenting these kinds of populations.
So I wanted to move beyond mortality
and actually look at living bodies
to see, well, okay, two
people actually have
some more direct evidence.
And so since I mentioned since 1999,
we've been working in
central lowland Bolivia
with the Tsimane, so again,
horticulturist population
that share many similarities
with hunter-gatherers,
their fertility is quite high,
their fairly high pathogen load,
most of their diet, not all their diet
basically coming from the land, from fish,
from their fields and also from wild game.
Taking advantage of the French government
donating a 16-slice CT scanner,
just a mere 10 hours and
several days in a canoe away,
we brought people to the CT scanner
to get a more direct
measure of atherosclerosis
through looking at coronary
arterial calcification
based on thoracic CT scans.
So using the exact same
methods for scoring
as in US studies, what
we compared Americans
to the Tsimani, it actually turns out that
well, the Tsimanis, these are here in red,
there is evidence of
atherosclerosis, of calcification,
but the levels are much lower
than what we see in the US.
Now the mesa, this is
the multi-ethnic study
of atherosclerosis.
These are asymptomatic
people without heart disease
or diabetes that are in the sample.
So compared to those,
the percentage of people
with any calcification
is much, much lower.
And in fact, the Tsimani reached a level
that the Americans have, that's
a gap of over 20, 25 years.
And so one easier way of thing about this
and this kind of obscure
calcification scoring
is what's called the arterial age,
and this is basically what age,
based on the CAC score you have,
was that at the equivalent
of someone in the MACE study.
And compared to what you would expect
based on just the calcification score,
that the Tsimanis show
evidence that basically
estimated arterial ages, that are about
20, 25 years younger than
their chronological age.
But the great thing about
working with living people,
if the story ended there, we might say,
well, look, just like we
found with the mummies,
there's atherosclerosis in the Tsimani.
But here at the clinical
findings really suggest
minimum manifestations of atherosclerosis.
So over the past decade,
we found minimal obesity,
hypertension, cigarette smoking,
moderate-high physical activity,
low cholesterol levels,
low your bad, your low density
lipoprotein cholesterol,
low blood glucose, so all the risk factors
are fairly minimal.
And then if we actually
look based on EKGs,
if we look for evidence of past infarcts,
over 1,100 EKGs, we've
looked at people 40 and up,
maybe one case of an infarct
looked at by our team of cardiologists.
And even that, a couple
of the cardiologists
think it's dubious.
And also based on other evidence with EKGs
and also with ultrasound,
evidence of preserved systolic
and diastolic function.
And it's not the case
that the young people
that have these conditions,
then are dying at early ages,
or that these people have
high case fatality rates,
so based on verbal autopsies,
over the past 15 years,
we don't see very much evidence at all,
in fact, like maybe one case of someone
who may have died of a heart attack.
So there really doesn't
seem like there's evidence
of mortality selection that is explaining
these differences away.
Now this is in spite of the fact,
you know they have some protective factors
but they also have very
high levels of inflammation.
And you know, in the past 20 years or so,
it's well-known that inflammation
is a major risk factor.
In fact, it is a
fundamental to the process
of what we know about atherosclerosis,
and by a number of biomarkers,
CE reactive protein is one
many of you might be familiar with because
you often get it done
by your own clinician.
They have very high levels
and cumulative levels
over their life course, levels that would
basically associate with
having heart disease
amongst ourselves.
And they also have low levels of
the high-density lipoproteins
or good cholesterol.
So a few take-home messages
for a larger biomedical field.
First of all, it doesn't seem
like the inflammation story
is very complete, that the
same kind of risk factor
might not exert the same
types of effects everywhere.
I mean, probably would not have known that
if we didn't look at populations that are
I guess as Katie brought up,
looking at non-weird populations,
and particularly
populations that experience
lots of infection and have very different
kind of lifestyle than we have.
And in fact, not only do they have
high levels of inflammation,
but biomarkers of inflammation
are either unrelated
or in some ways oppositely
associated with our measures
of arterial calcification
and other indicators
of atherosclerosis.
And it could be that
inflammation that we experience
from cigarette smoking, from obesity,
the so-called sterile inflammation
might have different
effects than inflammation
that is induced under the conditions
more representative of the past
which would be more from infection.
But also, there are other
types of infections,
particularly helminths,
these are intestinal worms,
our old friends that we've carried with us
for long, long periods of
our evolutionary history,
that they exert regulatory
effects on the immune system
and also anti-inflammatory
effects that might perhaps
protect against the
otherwise destructive effects
of inflammation.
And the other take-home is that
what we consider average
might not be really normal.
So James O'Keefe, a physician
back in the early 2000s,
argued the case based on randomized
placebo-controlled studies with statins
that if you look at
the chronic LDL levels,
and you looked at a whole bunch of things,
this is just the decrease over time
in the lumenal diameter, so
the interior of the artery,
but you gotta change
the Y axis and make it
heart attacks and other cardiac events,
that when you actually looked at
how the occurrence of these things
in relation to the chronic LDL levels,
it seemed to be a somewhat
linear relationship
to the point where if you draw the line,
that you would expect
to almost zero events.
In this particular graph,
it would mean basically
a slowing of atherosclerosis
to the point of stopping
at a level of about 70
or just less than 70,
and so they were arguing
in a series of papers
that the optimal LDL should
be something between 50 to 70,
whereas your typical recommendations,
at least up until 2013
when the statin-based
recommendations changed
so that we're not reaching a target level.
But it used to be that
a hundred was a level.
But it actually turns out
there's a decent amount
of heart attacks in the
region between 70 to 100.
And this is just from the Tsimane,
but if we looked at other populations
it would be a similar case.
The distribution of the
LDL here in the Tsimane
compared to Americans, and
it might be a little hard,
sorry, to see the numbers, but
the mode in the average there
is about 70 for the Tsimane,
whereas about 85% of Americans
have LDL higher than that.
And that what's yellow there
is in that 70 to 100 region
that basically many of
Americans would fall into,
even if they were taking statins.
So less than 70 is a
hunter-gatherer level of LDL
that might be more extreme
but probably very difficult
for us as omnivores to reach,
unless perhaps you're taking statins.
So just to summarize and conclude,
atherosclerosis is present
just like we observed in the mummies,
but it's less pervasive
than we see in the West.
So certain features of
cardiovascular aging
may be universal.
So you might see some calcifications
and stiffening of the arteries,
there's some declines,
they might be delayed in
systolic and diastolic function,
but they occur nonetheless.
Yet the clinical manifestation,
so whether it's heart
attacks, hyper tension,
peripheral arterial disease, strokes,
that those themselves
might not be universal,
and were likely very rare throughout
human evolutionary
history, despite the fact
that we can observe
calcifications in these mummies.
And also I think it behooves us
to revisit common risk factors.
That inflammation might be high
in hunter-gatherer populations,
but immune function
might be better regulated in
a very different environment,
particularly in presence of a
more diverse set of pathogens.
And it also raises the
question of what is normal,
what are the target levels
of different biomarkers
like LDL that we should be reaching,
what might they have been like
over the course of evolutionary history.
And to take advantage of the fact,
if we hadn't looked at a
population like the Tsimane,
these non weird populations,
so we can actually learn quite a bit
about our own health in, say, the U.S.,
by focusing on people that
are more likely to have
certain types of infections
that could be cardio-protective.
Even a lot of our standard
model organisms in the lab
are infection-free, and so
there might some limitations
of what can be gained.
And also taking advantage of the fact,
and the horror of the fact,
that all indigenous
populations around the world
are in different states of flux,
so it's a kind of quasi-natural laboratory
for looking at the changes
in lifestyle and environment
on how that shapes increases
in Type II diabetes risk
and in heart disease.
And so it's sort of untapped
territory that very,
in fact I don't know any
biomedically-oriented folks
that are working in these
populations to try to learn more
about the underlying ideology.
And so for the future,
one thing that a take-home message
is if the story was just that
"Look, exercise more,
eat well, don't smoke."
We already knew.
Those are your standard Framingham
Study kinda risk factors.
And I think those do
make a big difference.
But also, regulated immune function
in the presence of certain parasites
might also have some protective
aspects on their heart.
And that maybe in the future we might see
that the hygiene hypothesis,
this idea that we're not exposed
to the same type of critters
as we would have in the past,
that not only helps explain
auto-immune type diseases
currently, but also may be
extended to heart disease.
Thank you very much for your time.
(mellow piano music)
- So I will discuss today
the relation between
inflammation and metabolism
and metabolic homeostasis
and diseases susceptibility.
Inflammation is a protective response
to a variety of challenges
that we may experience,
including infection and injury
and various types of tissue
stress and malfunctions
and all the things that can go wrong.
All of them can induce
an inflammatory response
that meant to be protective.
And depending on the type of
challenge that we experience,
there's different physiological
or intended purpose
of the responses, such as
host defense from infection,
tissue repair response or restoration
of a normal state of the tissues.
And what is very interesting
about inflammation
and very clinically important is that
all these different
pathways to inflammation
can result in a variety
of pathological sequel,
including auto-immune diseases, sepsis,
fibrotic diseases, tumor growth,
and a variety of diseases for homeostasis
that are becoming more and more common
in modern lifestyles.
To give a very, very simplified
summary of inflammation
of inflammatory pathway.
When inducers of inflammation
such as pathogens or tissue
damage are encountered,
cells in our bodies, such as macrophages
and epithelial cells and so on
detect these inducers and produce various
inflammatory mediators,
including cytokines
that some of them were mentioned already.
And what these mediators do,
they act on practically
every tissue in the body
and they change some
functional characteristics
that intend to either cause elimination
of whatever caused inflammation,
or adaptation to the
presence of these conditions.
And why inflammation is so
broadly associated with diseases,
very symbolically, it
could be summarized here.
So for every trait,
including defense traits,
there are benefits and costs for defenses.
The cost are particularly pronounced.
And the traits would
be evolutionary stable
if the benefits are higher than the costs.
And anything in this
green part of the triangle
would be therefore potentially
evolutionary stable
and everything here would be unstable.
And the problem is that,
in the case of traits
that can provide very high
benefits such as survival,
the acceptable cost can also be very high.
And that leads to this type of picture
where the part of this upper triangle
that's on the right side
where benefit can still outweigh the cost
but in terms of the
absolute value of the cost,
this would be already, from
the patient perspective
at least, and the doctor's perspective,
this would be already in the disease zone.
This would be conditions
that we would experience as
something that is
definitely not well being
and doctors would diagnose
as being various types
of pathological or disease
conditions even though
they still provide more
benefit than the cost.
And what we're interested
in is in the biology
of this upper right corner,
where the high benefits
associated with very high
cost and where we basically
on the edge of the chaos or transition
into the pathological states
that can be potentially lethal.
And this type of biology deals with
not just common conditions,
like mild infections or mild anomalies,
but it has to do with,
essentially biology of survival.
What are the kinds of
mechanisms that are employed
by our system, by our
organism in order to survive
critical conditions?
The ones the are just
one step away from death.
And this is just in a very schematic way
summarized here, so if we
consider this type of disease tree
there're many conditions that we can
one step away from health
this various common mild illnesses,
this has conditions that make you go
to see a primary care physician.
If there're complications
of this conditions
you get referred to some
internal medicine specialist.
These are more complex diseases,
but you can still recover
and go back to health.
And in severe cases you can get into this
critical illness state
when you get into ICU.
And you still can recover from here,
and in this critical illness state,
which is conditions like
sepsis, pneumonia, heart attack,
brain damage and so forth.
In these conditions you are
one step away from this tree
proximal mechanisms that
lead directly to death.
And these are points of no return,
which is respiratory failure,
cardiovascular failure,
or damage to the brain areas
that control respiration
and cardiovascular function.
So we're interested in what happens here,
what kind of mechanisms may be evolved
to prevent this transition
into this point of no return.
The case I will discuss today has to do
with this very enigmatic
and very interesting
and familiar to everyone,
set of conditions known
as sickness behaviors.
This is something everybody
in this room experience
when you have flu or any
other type of severe infection
or other types of acute
illness, we all experience
this set of conditions
such as loss of appetite,
social withdrawal, fatigue, sleepiness
and so on and so forth.
So these are all stereotypic conditions
that are associated with acute illness,
most commonly with acute infections.
So flue symptoms would
all be in that category.
And the biology of sickness behavior
has not been really well-understood,
although there were early
studies that demonstrated
that sickness behavior
is not just a consequence
of system being destroyed by a pathogen,
but rather these are motivated behaviors,
in other words they are
intended by the organism
for some reason.
And there's been many speculations
that whether there is
aspects of sickness behavior,
perhaps held the immune
system to fight infection
or maybe there's some other
way that they may contribute
to dealing with acute illness.
So we were interested in investigating
aspects of acute illness,
including loss of appetite
and change in sleeping patterns,
and how they may contribute
to survival of the acute illness.
So there are two ways we
can survive an infection
or any other challenge for that matter.
We can either resist it, so
in the case of infection,
normally where we would be in this state,
where we're healthy and there's a low
or a negligible pathogen load,
and as we get infected
and pathogen expand,
we can become ill as
indicated by this position,
and from here, we can
either go back to health
by getting rid of
pathogen, which is the role
of the immune system,
and this is referred to
a resistance to disease,
or we can adapt to the
presence of the pathogen
and go back to the healthy
state despite microbial load.
And this would be referred
to as increased tolerance
to infection or tolerance to damage.
There are two ways that
pathogens cause damage.
One is directly through tissue
destruction through toxins,
viral infections and so forth.
And the second more common
way that pathogens infections
call illness is due to
damage by the inflammation
caused by infection.
And so we were interested in figuring out
whether sickness behaviors
provide benefit first of all,
secondly whether they provide
benefit because they promote
immune function and
resistance to infection,
or whether they provide
benefit by promoting
tissue protection and tolerance
to inflammatory damage
or pathogen induced damage.
Just like in humans and
mice or in any animals
that've been studied all
the way back to insects,
when they are ill with acute
infection, they stop eating,
this is food consumption
in mice after they received
a dose of listeria infection.
This is common food
poisoning type of infection.
They stop eating and until
they start clearing infection
and they start recovering and
then they start eating again.
But there's a very profound anorexia
associated with infection
as you can see here.
So some studies done over
40 years ago actually found
that in the model of listeria infection,
if mice are force-fed
then mortality increases.
And this is what we reproduce here.
So this is showing survival
of mice that are given
LD 50 dose of listeria, those
that kills half of mice,
and this is what's shown here.
And if they're force-fed
then all of them die.
And they were fed just 20%
of daily caloric intake,
so they're not really stuffed with food,
they're just given a little bit of food
and that kills them.
And the food that we use is actually
the same food that's used in ICU units.
And then we ask what
component of food kills.
So we gave them separately proteins,
fat, and sugar.
And it turns out that sugar
alone or glucose alone
was sufficient to kill them,
whether it was given orally
or intravenously.
So just giving them a small dose of sugar,
only 2% of normal daily
caloric intake of glucose,
was sufficient to kill 100% of mice.
Conversely, if we gave them
glucose inhibitor called 2DG,
2-deoxyglucose, it's a
modified form of glucose
that cannot be metabolized so
it blocks glucose utilization
then 100% of mice would survive.
And importantly, this was not
because the immune system was
affected in its ability to treat
to get rid of the pathogen,
and it's not because
there was high dose of
higher magnitude of inflammation,
because there were not different between
mice given glucose or
not as you can see here.
So this indicated that
mice survived or died
from this manipulation
because of the affect
on tissue protection,
not on the immune function itself.
So then ask what would happen
in the most severe condition, like sepsis.
Sepsis is the condition when
infection becomes systemic,
when it gets into blood.
In this case it's a bacterial
sepsis that's mimicked
by giving mice this
component and a toxin LPS.
And as you can see here, if
mice given LPS or septic mice,
if they are given food, they die.
Compared to a control,
where they're just given saline solution.
And importantly if
they're just given sugar,
then they all drop dead.
But most excitingly they're
just getting the simple drug
that blocks glucose utilization,
then 100% of them can
be rescued from sepsis.
And sepsis is a really
terrible intractable condition
that is still a very common
cause of death in ICUs.
So again, the mortality
or protection from death
in these manipulations was not dependent
on the degree of
inflammation as shown here,
was example of a couple
of inflammatory mediators.
And again, indicating that it was due to
increased tissue protection from damage
caused by severe inflammation
that is associated with sepsis.
Then we asked what would happen
in a different type of infection.
So, so far I showed bacterial infection
and bacterial sepsis, and
now we ask what would happen
in influenza virus infection.
So when mice are infected with
flu virus, again they undergo
this period of anorexia
when they stop eating
until they start recovering.
And if they're force-fed,
to our great surprise,
they actually survive better.
So this is now giving almost
lethal dose of flu infection,
most mice die, but when
they're given that food
most of them survived.
And also if they're given glucose
that also provided partial protection,
and if they're given 2DG glucose inhibitor
then all of them dropped dead.
So it was exact opposite to what happened
in bacterial infection
and bacterial sepsis.
And again, the effect of glucose
was not due to its impact
on inflammatory response.
So in viral infections
it's a different type
of inflammatory response,
which is dominated
by interference shown
here, they're the same.
And those of burden of
the virus in the lungs
was also the same, was not different.
Again, suggesting the
effects are due to impact
on tolerance to tissue damage.
And the data that I'm not gonna
show, but I summarized here,
what we found is that death
from viral inflammation
was associated with
decline in vital functions,
like respiration, blood pressure, so on,
suggesting that there was a failure
in autonomic control
centers in the brain stem.
And if mice are given food or glucose,
then these declines in autonomic
functions could be rescued,
they're given 2DG, they're enhanced.
In contrast, death from
bacterial sepsis was associated
with neuronal damage in the mid-brain area
and the death was immediately
proceeded by convulsions.
And these were blocked by 2DG
and they were enhanced by glucose.
So we did PET scan analysis and found
that glucose utilization under conditions
of bacterial inflammation
versus viral inflammation
was very different,
and it segregated exactly
to this to this brain areas.
Such that in viral inflammation
it was primarily in brain stem,
and in bacterial inflammation
it was in mid-brain area.
The increased delivery
of glucose to this areas
related to the impact of
glucose or glucose inhibitors
on the damage to these areas.
And then we asked what does
the mechanism of damage
and what's happening there.
So I will just summarize
that part of the study.
What we found was that in the
case of viral inflammation,
what happens with cells that
are infected with a virus,
one of the things that happens,
there is particular type of
cellular stress response,
known as unfolded protein
response, that has two branches.
One branch tries to adapt
to this stress condition
and to resolve it, and if that fails,
the second branch would kill
the cells, as a second option.
And this death from this
response is mediated
by this particular gene called CHOP,
it's a transcription factor.
And what is known is that glucose
deprivation can exacerbate
in unfolded protein response,
this stress response pathway.
And so we hypothesized
that that brain stem area,
the neurons in the brain stem,
for reasons that remain mysterious,
underwent this excessive
unfold protein response stress
that was ameliorated by
glucose and exacerbated by 2DG.
And then we asked whether
this pathway of cell death
or neuronal damage mediated
by this gene is involved.
And for that we asked whether
mice that have a mutation
in this gene, whether
they would be rescued
from the effect of such
inflammatory manipulation.
And indeed what we found, if
we just look at this blue line,
these are mice that have infection,
that have viral inflammation,
and they'd given 2DG they all die,
and if they don't have that gene CHOP,
then they all survive.
And so the mechanism here
is related to a blockade
of this pathway for neuron dysfunction.
And finally in the case of
sepsis or bacterial inflammation,
fasting metabolism that
protected them from death
was related to the switch
from normal fat metabolism
to a fasted metabolism,
which there's a switch to
fuels from glucose to
ketones, and that which was
necessary for mice to survive sepsis.
And this is shown here,
that giving glucose blocked
transition to fasting metabolism
and deletion of the gene
that is responsible for keone production,
made mice susceptible to sepsis.
As I mentioned immediately before death,
mice had convulsion in sepsis.
So what we did in this
final set of experiments,
if we gave the mice anti-epileptic drug
called valporic acid,
then we could rescue them
from death even when
they're given glucose.
And so that indicated that
the reason that that worked
is because valporic acid, unlike
this other drug shown here,
which is Keppra, which is
also anti-convulsion drug,
valporic acid, one of its
mechanism is related to
the effect through the same
effect that ketones have
on a particular class
of enzymes in the cell.
So I will summarize it here,
that there are two
different pathways to death,
and fasting metabolism
is protective in one case
and detrimental in the other case.
And the final, the implication
for human treatment in ICU
is that all clinical trials done so far,
with nutrient manipulation
in ICU units have been done
on patients that have not been separated
based on cause of sepsis,
bacterial versus viral.
And the results of the studies were mixed.
And we think that it's because
they were not separated
and they basically
cancelled each other out.
So now we are planning to
conduct a clinical trial
where we'll separate them,
based on causes of sepsis.
So this is the summary and
finally this work was done
by three very talented
scientist in the lab,
Harding Luan, Sarah Huen, and Andrew Wang.
And we had help from
other colleagues at Yale,
and thank you for your attention.
(mellow piano music)